virtual reality man I can't wait for it
I don't have one of those I have a deaf
kit one a deaf kit - I have a boo-boo
cardboard and I've tried the Samsung VR
um but yeah and you watch porn with that
maybe but anyway i'm ryan right pleasure
to meet you pleasure to meet you it's
just gonna be real here
hello guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm
Jessica Villarreal from the channel best
game show ever they have more than
10,000 followers if you like gaming
you'll like Jessica that should be your
tagline I know
well my tagline is Villa got to be real
because my last name Villarreal anyway
we're gonna check out top five shocking
moments of the GTA series by zooming TV
games let's get our game on she's by GTA
5 PC I have played
part three and by city that's not as far
as it's gone San Andreas I played I want
to get back in to GTA cuz every time I
see a trailer I'm like I mean it's
pretty I mean if you played San Andreas
in Vice City
it's a great escape and a great escape
as in game Grand Theft Auto 3 turns 14
this week so now is a great time to take
a look at all the shocking moments this
series has given us over the years many
to choose from here are our top 5 most
shocking GTA moments action whoa no bat
big 12 inches that is regulation baby
[Music]
cut who is this idiot you you why are
you in my space why what is all this
crap
[Music]
by now it's completely normal to pick up
prostitutes in a GTA game but back in
2001 this wasn't the case the mainstream
media and in particular lawyer Jack
Thompson were outraged at Grand Theft
Auto 3 they called the game a disgusting
murder simulator that two shooters kill
prostitutes and police officers
[Music]
ironically the headlines spawned by this
controversy only boosted sales and
encouraged Rockstar to put more shocking
stuff in their future games so I am Owen
Clements ah
Here I am what I am more shocking stuff
came in the form of full frontal male
nudity I want to see the name it was the
first time ever that a piece of DLC
featured 3d male genitalia yeah and it
surprised a lot of people now that you
mention it starting to feel a little
queasy he's looking directly at it no
secrets here pal the scene in question
is great at providing flirtatious
glimpses of Congressman Stubbs junk it
didn't cause the uproar Rockstar most
likely expected but we're still shocking
nonetheless penises are look out for
those who help me a blackmailer with the
coaches killing hookers unity Cohen
hookers with your penis Wow every day
the introduction of Trevor really shows
that he's a psychopath nobody wants to
mess with he starts off by banging the
girlfriend of Johnny who is the biker
you played in the lost in the Damned
when Johnny says something about it he
gets glass in the face and savagely
kicked to death brutally killing off a
very likeable character was a shocking
move that upset a lot of fans oh we're
talking to you huh [ __ ] Johnny
so yes the coffee is the name of what
was meant to be an inaccessible minigame
in grand theft auto san andreas a Dutch
programmer found the hidden sex scene
and released a mod that gave players
access to it I never understood the
phrase meaningless what followed was a
storm of lawsuits and a reclassification
of the game as adult only this led to
the biggest recall in Gd a history and
force rockstar to re-release the game
with the hot coffee content removed one
expensive cup of coffee that didn't stop
people from business world did you find
it the playable torture scene with
Trevor is the most shocking scene in the
history of Grand Theft Auto you can
waterboard the fugitive
[Music]
break and the college electrocute him
with a car battery and extract a tooth
with a pair of pliers good way to make a
man talk is to stop him being able to
die the scene isn't meant to be fun
it's there to make a statement about
torture methods that still exist today
to extract information from prisoners
great sure gamers around the world yeah
I'm sure that's why they got so favorite
shocking moment in the GTA series let us
know in the comments below check out
zooming TV games for all sorts of cool
game videos bring shapes and we aren't
afraid to get a little naughty we all
gave a wide variety of hooks who are
always up for a laugh and check out zoom
in TV games
[Music]
I don't know what that was thanks guys
this mic was on the whole time right
okay so sweet I hate it when that mics
off yes
what a fun channel that is a fun channel
and top five with these guys look like
they have a great personality I like the
fact that their videos are efficient
yeah
but they actually include footage
however I'm a little bit dissatisfied
that we didn't get to see that guy's
penis
yes flaccid penis no but we don't know
if it was laughing we need that's the
thing the point we don't know now now
what's left to mystery now I have to
play the game - [ __ ] hey now I got an
excuse to play the game yeah yeah or
maybe maybe it's not an over terminal
for it that is more efficient what I
gotta say with this video is it really
made me wanna play GTA like all the
games again because I like how it didn't
just stick to one of the GTA is it one
of my other ones and what was the one
with the porno at the beginning oh uh
gosh I don't know we could look at it
again cuz I obviously didn't play this
one so it got me thinking like there
should be an RPG game for pornos Oh like
you get to choose what position you're
you're like the director and you're
telling the actors what - if GTA could
include that in some way I think we got
a very solid video right right right
right yeah and maybe a little too adult
for GTA cuz it's still kind of released
to the public I don't know I'm pretty
sure there's got to be some sort of
simulator out there that allows you to
do that I know that you can start doing
that with virtual reality oh well the
hot coffee the hot coffee thing was huge
Wenham that was discovered I've never
seen footage of it and I've heard of
that yeah that's great that's actually
they had to like it take it out of the
game then rewrite it right so basically
in the game one of the characters would
invite you back over to their home for
hot coffee and when you get in to the
home hot coffee was a euphemism for
something else and that's I guess that's
why they ended up taking it out of the
game that didn't stop people from
actually being able to like hack into it
and and still uh see it what was hot
coffee
meant Oh for bone and down that's what
hot coffee meant in the wall in the
games look is like she invited that she
invites you back to the house to for
some hot coffee oh so that's why I'm
just saying it's a euphemism but I
imagine the coffee's like brown and
liquidy yes I imagine it happens after
the penetration of a certain hole Oh
woody round and liquidy I miss ya you
just very careful yeah careful
took too much fiber right that day ya
know that's very inconsiderate of the
other person to be very inconsiderate my
reasons are gonna happen yeah I don't
like hot coffee I know don't like on my
guys coffee that's really gross if we're
talking about the same thing right now I
want to mention the moment where Trevor
kills Johnny hmm I do like that moment
because it's interesting how they killed
off such a likeable character I in such
an unexpected way liked it we didn't no
one saw I've heard of that I've like
seen gameplay GTA 5 I've never actually
played it myself a lot but to kill off
this lovable character is such a brave
and bold move really you know it comes
with backlash but it also comes with
these guys got balls yeah I feel like
when you do such a controversial
decision yeah there's gonna be some
backlash but I like how they did it in
an unexpected way which adds to Trevor's
menace right and they owned it they
didn't like go back and apologize or you
know they didn't go back and change the
game because you know everyone was
really upset about it like some other
games yeah but have done that in the
past yeah do you Mass Effect 3 like you
said it is a very bold move I don't like
you know the the Hollywood happy endings
things like where where a movie just
kind of pays fanservice and it's like
this is what the people are gonna want
so this is what we're gonna give them I
like it when they take it for a
curveball yeah
something you don't expect happen it has
to be a combination of giving the
audience what they want plus giving them
something unexpected you know and it's
like we want the unexpected but we also
want it to be what we want you know it's
like this weird combination the first
the top one they mentioned was the
torture scene
crazy and oh man okay first off anything
with teeth nananana oh yeah I'm not
making a [ __ ] reference right I'm not
although yes same thing applies right
but anything with teeth teeth pulling no
it's pretty gnarly know what I
appreciate is they were like we're
trying to send a message I am I'm like
so putting you in the hands actually
being the torturer and getting like a
sort of like high off of like beating
this guy to death is supposed to send
these kids a message and like come on
like supposed to make the player
uncomfortable and I'm like I don't know
and I might have know you're in control
the player you're having fun in some way
by controlling it right right girl dude
stop playing yeah and I don't think I
read many articles or people like I
stopped playing after the torture scene
no they're like I want to know more you
know be fun if they have this torture
scene in GTA 5 the video game but
instead of in the chair it was Donald
Trump oh are we getting political up in
here oh [ __ ] - Ryan just throwing a
political point you know who should be
doing it to him Bernie Sanders won't
make any sense cuz that's not Sanders
style oh well you know what no way it's
gonna be interesting I don't really have
strong political views I try to come
across like I do nor do I last time I
remember caring was when we got that
black guy for president uh-huh that
black yep what's the thing Rama Rama
yeah robot robot robot robot robot
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel listen if you guys are new today
there's this button right here click it
to subscribe to the real rejects I like
to say become a rejected a that's my
love a clever like that my clever name
for fans you can check out Jessica on
the best game ship is it just the best
or best game ship its best game show
check her out on best game show ever
it's a fun channel all gaming related
this girl knows what she's talking about
when it comes to games so I produced
created and yeah thank you
oh yeah and follow us on our social
networks because especially if the real
rejects get more followers we can
more product placement making money is
the art of happiness that's what I've
learned the more money you make the
happier you become it's true
so how me be happy by you doing
something for free which is follow me
dude that's all I got a bit bull and
then I make more money wouldn't you want
to help me out I have a hard job
watching videos then talking about them
talking about hot calm they say easy
work politics I want money